actualmente vivimos una de las etapas
más importantes de nuestra vida la
adolescencia esta etapa donde nos queda
un futuro inmenso por delante
sin embargo a esta corta edad tenemos
que tomar unas decisiones más
importantes que vamos a hacer de grandes
unos nos recomiendan es tener una
carrera universitaria ya que tiene un
mejor campo laboral
otros nos hacen exámenes de
conocimientos los cuales estados más
confundidos
hola mi nombre salvador yo les quiero
platicar la historia de un chico de
chico como de 17 años el cual momento
entré a la universidad se acercaba más y
más
sin saber quiero estudiar decir toda una
experiencia la cual lo va a cambiar para
siempre
decidirse durante un mes a flores italia
a estudiar la historia del arte
cuando llegó se sentía muy desubicado
tenía dos sentimientos encontrados uno
estaba entre tímido y angustiado porque
no iba a ver a sus papás durante más de
un mes para la ve está emocionado con
ganas de salir descubrir todo así que
agarro sus maletas y llegó a florencia
y ahí empezó el primer reto cómo me voy
a comunicar
este chico ya tenía una que otra clase
de italiano en línea pero nada del otro
mundo sólo sabe decir yo solo un regato
que manié lamela que quiere decir yo soy
un chico con una manzana como ven nada
funcional
sin embargo la señal con la que se
espera este chico hablaba y entender un
poco el español así que le ayudó mucho
ya que decía que le podía decir las
palabras las cuales podía utilizar al
siguiente día tenía que ir a la escuela
donde iba a tomar la mayor de las clases
las maestras de estación con esta la
logística y vio que casi no está en el
salón ya que las mayorías de las clases
tenían tanto en las calles como los
museos de florencia
pasaron los días pasaron las semanas
este chico estaba sentado en un museo
y se dio cuenta de algo que
verdaderamente lo cambió para siempre
estaba dejamos de ver el arte
ya no lo veía como antes lo hacía ya no
lo apreciaba como antes lo hacía este
chico ahora empezaba a vivir el arte
empezaba a entender más y más conocí a
los autores conocía su contexto
histórico sus ideologías entre un sinfín
más de cosas
este chico además de estar en florencia
cada fin de semana viajaba a un lugar
distinto como roma venecia pizza y al
lugar donde iba intentaba aprender lo
máximo posible
por ejemplo en san gimignano un pueblito
medieval el cual tiene la heladería más
deliciosa del mundo
o en roma como conocer la iglesia más la
gestión que san pedro en el vaticano
obviamente no todo fue color de rosa en
este viaje uno fue que estaba en roma
este chico por de fortuna no tenía la
celular que cubriera en esa ciudad así
que pues quería solucionarlo y se compró
un mapa físico pero clara no lo
soluciono convirtió una camioneta de 10
minutos a un museo en una travesía de
dos horas
al lugar donde quería simplemente no lo
encontraba sin embargo en esta travesía
él y sus amigos se encontraron una
tienda de productos importados vieron en
la vitrina los productos de la costeña y
los que tenemos aquí también estaban
allá se emocionaron y querían comprar
todo sin embargo está exageradamente
caro así que optaron por comprar nuestro
topos una salsa se sentaron en un parque
a contar historias de cómo este viaje
los había cambiado
este chico nunca olvidará la vez que
entro a la capilla sixtina
como ya les dije imagínense estar un
sábado en roma en verano lleno de
turistas donde todos quieren ver todo y
todo un desastre
el museo del vaticano estaba
completamente lleno
no podías platicar ya que descripción
muy fuerte sin embargo la muestra que
está acompañando nos guía a un hacerlas
que mágicamente está vacía lo sentó y
los puso en contexto porque miguel ángel
había pintado hasta ahora
se pararon y en torno a la capilla la
capilla obviamente llena de gente con
ese murmullo tan característico sin
embargo este chico no le importo se paró
justo en medio y medio hacia arriba
y vio la creación
yo cada una de esas obras hasta llegar
al fresco principal que está detrás del
altar
si por un momento ese sitio
completamente solo está tan concentrado
viendo cada uno veía cómo se movían como
él pertenecía cada fresco se imaginaba
miguelángel trepado en un andamio
pintado cada uno de estos frescos
verdaderamente fue mágico
por desgracia este viaje estaba llegando
a su final este chico se entristeció ya
que pensaba que estaba viviendo un sueño
todo lo que había era perfecto todo lo
que comía delicioso
él estaba encantado
sin embargo se dio cuenta de que todo lo
que había visto llevaba décadas sino es
que siglos en esos lugares así que sabía
lo que no sé diciendo un adiós sino un
hasta pronto
para los que nos tratan yo soy el chico
de su historia
un más de un mes en europa te cambia
completamente en el primero una persona
muy responsable aquí tienes que hacer
tanto que tienes que hacer cargo tanto
de tu tiempo de tus gastos lavar la ropa
que vas a comer hoy entre el sinfín de
cosas también aprendí que el mundo que
están más globalizado hiperconectado
aquí tengo dos claros ejemplos uno
estaba caminando por florencia en las
calles y escuché que un señor estaba
tocando el acordeón me acerqué porque la
canción de magia familiar cuando lo vi
de frente estaba tocando la canción del
despacito de luis fonsi
realmente fue algo claro también otro es
que está en la calle donde vendían
souvenirs
y un adulto hindú se me acercó diciendo
es el amigo más barato que te ya
que yo ni el latino es impresionante que
una persona que inició en la india está
en florencia y le está ofreciendo a un
mexicano algo que fuego si fuera de
tepito fue algo único
así es que chavos si alguna vez intentas
ubicados desganados
sin saber qué va hacer en sus vidas
salgan se vean a conocer este mundo
probablemente es maravilloso
así que para encontrarse uno mismo se
tienen que perder de vez en cuando y
como lo dijo el artista florentino
leonardo da vinci el aprendizaje
mediante las vivencias el única manera
de entender las cosas